did you ever play the game cruising USA
at an arcade where every time you would
pass the checkpoint you would get an
additional 35 seconds and you hear a
girl say something like this maybe she
didn't sound like Mario but something
like that right and you get that
additional 35 seconds you were so
excited I got to go pass to other guys
so I can get another checkpoint that's
exactly what it is to be an entrepreneur
you're in survival mode and you need
additional 35 days of savings to allow
you to grow your business then you need
70 days of savings six months of savings
a year of savings two years of savings
three years of savings then you're
completely grown your business and
scaling it because now you can you know
constantly thinking about your next
strategy so today the reason I'm telling
you this message is because most of the
time we have so many amateur
entrepreneurs don't make it because they
do so many different activities that are
purely time wasters instead of growing
their businesses and I'm going to talk
about 16 of them here today with the
most important in my opinion is number
one and that this is what it is doing
$10 an hour job so make spend what I
mean by doing $10 an hour jobs I like
shining shoes I like ironing clothes I
like doing those types of things and I
remember one time one of my mentors said
you know do you want to make $10 an hour
I said no I said then why do you keep
doing $10 an hour jobs I said what do
you mean he said you keep shining shoes
you keep doing this you keep liking
those types of things you got to get
somebody else to help you out so what
happened
I went 100% drycleaners even when I
couldn't afford it I was broke I went
100% drycleaners I went 100% somebody
else helping me shine my shoes and I
gave money to a business
I got an assistant to do my paperwork
for me to do the filing for me to do all
of those things for me
to drop my car off at Jeffrey Luke to
get an oil change to get a car wash
literally all of those activities were
done by somebody else and it became a
matchup system to me I had somebody do
those things for me where Allah allowed
me to do the other things even
housecleaning it was somebody else doing
it where it's not me doing it now why is
that important to do you got to get an
assistant so you can leverage your time
do not let $10 an hour job get you out
of business where you end up going back
and getting a job that pays you only $10
an hour focus on what grows your
business point number two blame
too many times I've made this mistake so
many times at the beginning stages as an
entrepreneur I can't believe he didn't
buy I can't believe she said this how
could you say no to this that person
didn't close it was this person's fault
it was that person's fault and what
would happen is my day boom it's 9:30
what I get done today nothing what
happened today how did I lose today and
you go back in you backtrack huh man I
got upset at her at 8:45 and all day
today I've been thinking about this I
just lost the day of my life what a
waste of a day simply because I blamed
her for why my business isn't growing
how is it her fault it's not her fault
so there was nothing good that comes out
of blaming anybody for anything that
happens to your business that hurts you
no blame it could be somebody else's
fault that's fine what could you have
done to improve this so solution when
you feel like blaming and wasting four
six seven eight hours of your date
purely take responsibility immediately
and what could I have done move on next
don't even think about it try to get
your brain to be you know putting less
time into it so you normally stress out
about it for four hours go to three
hours go to two hours go to one hour go
to thirty minutes ten minutes in a
minute you're upset for why can't leave
this just happened boom out of the state
you move on you forgot about it right
point number three worrying about going
out of business okay you can go out of
business by constantly worrying about
going out of business and a lot of
people do that when we first started our
company PHP agency' one the best advice
I got from a friend of mine bill he said
look people can talk about about you
people can sue you people can do
whatever they want to do to put you out
of business there's one thing nobody can
do no one can stop you from working all
you can do is work from day till night
until you make it and guess what I did I
said you know what you're absolutely
right we came out and we got to work and
everything ended up working on our favor
I can stress that about anything else
why am I worrying what worry for what
there was nothing to worry about we're
either going to make it or we're not
going to make it and if we work we're
going to be able to make the business
work and it ended up working for us so
don't spend a lot of time worrying now
do be paranoid but be paranoid and take
action instead of worry and be
immobilized where you're not moving
because worry immobilizes up pare
Noah makes an action point here's the
next three things we got to do not go
out of it here's the three things we got
to make sure that person is happy make
sure this is that's the paranoia part
not the worry part it's a complete
different emotion five constantly
thinking about what competitors are
doing I see a lot of times with this
person's doing this that person's
newness is person's doing this I hired
somebody one time and it didn't work out
too well
strong person it just was a bad fit and
the reason why I didn't work out is
because this person was a typical
corporate person who kept you know he
came from another person another
competitor and all he kept giving me is
here's how they do this brochure here's
how they do this marketing piece here's
how they do that here's how they do this
here's how they do this and finally I
said I don't want any of it and he says
what do you mean this is great I said I
don't want none of it why don't you want
any of it I don't want any of it because
I it's we're not trying to be like
everybody else we want to create new
content I don't care what our do you
know they just came out with this
brochure I don't care I don't care what
they just came out with you know do you
know they just did this let's get on
their conference call I have never once
gotten on my competitors conference call
they get on our conference call Aven at
one time got on our competitors
conference call why to do what what am I
going to get on there for what I want to
know about my competitors conference
call I get the numbers all the time get
on this conference call now - one time
since we start a PHP have I gone on a
competitors conference called not a
single time I don't want to hear it why
let me tell you why so this is not
coming from an arrogant place I'll
explain to you why if our strategies and
vision and ideas only are predicated
based on what our competitors come out
of I'm always a step behind why would I
do that I don't want to be a step behind
it's more about what are we doing next
what do we need next where's the market
where's the economy going where's the
demographic what's the demand what's
going on with this what's going on it's
always thinking that way instead now
they can get all the content from us I'm
totally fine I regularly get people that
say Pat you realize what content you're
putting out everybody is using the
marketplace from you that's totally fine
I enjoy doing this this is a way of
bringing value to everybody else but we
also know what we're doing there's many
things that we're now going to just
openly tell everybody on our strategies
but the key is this there is nothing
good that comes about constantly
thinking about what your competitors are
doing if you can't
only thinking about that now there are
times that you need to make adjustments
and call audibles and all that other
stuff but work more on your own idea
abilities than what your competitors are
doing to come out with ideas if you work
on yourself on your strategies you're
eventually going to be beating everybody
if you work on constantly beating your
prior best whatever your prior business
and the company prior best and volume
prior best in revenues progress and
subscribers progress and whatever it is
progress and licensing prime if you
constantly focus on that then eventually
within a few years you're gonna catch
yourself only competing with a handful
of people in like whoa okay big boy big
girl big guys Vick Vick Wow okay we're
running together cool let's see what we
can do next five years
boom innovate innovate innovate compete
compete compete innovate innovate yeah
there's only two other guys all right
cool let's let's see who's gonna win it
this year now we're going for the
heavyweight let's see who wins oh you
got an app that I got knocked out got my
you know and then you grow like if you
can't see think about the competitors
you'll be so stressed out all day long
you won't get anything done focus on
your game focus on your abilities on
what you need to do point number five
turn off notifications on your phone I
think too many times a time-waster is
you know there's 17 notifications the
only notifications I get is from cyber
dust and text those are the tune of you
notifications I get why cyber dust the
reason why cyber dust because I run my
business so any updates I want to know
what's going on and I get it from text
because I believe in my main core guys
who are working directly with me if I'm
in a position to pick up the phone and
respond I believe in responding
immediately now there are some people
that like to not respond immediately
because it's like a power play let me
not get back within two three four hours
I'm running a business there's a part of
the business that's not emotion it's
pure logic logically it's more valuable
to get back information to people that
are your main main main people that
you're not not talking everybody this is
a list of short list of people that you
do that with but for the most part
notifications turn them off you'll be
able to get on the notifications you
need to you'll find out when you need to
check what's going on if everything is
nowadays you can have Fox notification
ESPN or we can CNN notification Facebook
notification YouTube notification
Twitter everything is notification you
your day is filled with notifications
nothing gets done so solution keep to
notifications on text and cyberdust or
whatever use in that's communication
turn the rest off seven six next point
six time with a six time waster
constantly hiring new people for new
positions because you're not willing to
pay well enough let me explain what I
mean by this I see this happening over
and over and over again somebody brings
an assistant they stay with them for 18
months and this person is too cheap to
go past a certain amount of number then
they need to hire another assistant then
they bring another person that person
stays with them for five months they
learn everything they're not willing to
give another race that person leaves you
need to train another system let me ask
a question with this do you need to
understand this part I've made this
mistake but I want to explain something
to you here with this listen how much
does it cost for you to train somebody
to know what you like no you're good no
you're bad know the things the irks you
don't like know your language know your
thoughts know the tips you like the food
you like the coffee everything you like
how to run system email filter is
driving back off a CRM how long does it
take for somebody to learn all those
things now this is the next question how
much is that worth to you what is the
value of that to you
what is it valued up to you now let's
take it to a whole different level how
much is a social capital of work to you
they've been to your birthday parties
you've been to their birthday party
there's relevance there's a relationship
there's value there's things there what
is that worth to you you want to start
out all over again with somebody else
you want to constantly cheap about and
lose that person or do you want to say
you know what this person's no lawyer
with me so I had a very simple way I
believe in sacrifice if a person comes
in and they sacrifice I like to reward
big later on if you're willing to
comfortable and sacrifice I don't have
prom taking care of you later on but I'm
sacrificing you got to sacrifice as well
so there were certain things that I
believe in if I had somebody that
started off with me an assistant Alexis
she started off with me years ago and
she was doing part-time I think I was
painted for 400 bucks or $800 a month
very very part-time and then she went to
1,500 2,000 3,000 4,000 5,000 6,000 this
is her salary and she just started as a
regular assistant she was 21 years old
20 years old 20 I don't know how old she
was
many years ago and now she's at a whole
different place I can say this story
about a lot of different people I had
somebody that started off with us and he
was a former executive and he started
off because the former place he was at
they weren't willing to pay him the
money that they could because they were
making adjustments he came through we
started off small and now he's making
nearly multi six figures salary it's not
a bad deal started off with a lot less
than that
but he moved up and he's never made that
kind of money before loyalty value and
it's not worth going to do the whole
training process now now then it comes
to a point where there's a value for
that position as well so I'm not talking
about this is continuously grown it's
purely based on value if that person's
bringing value they're going to put a
for what they're worth but it's not
continuously if a person is eventually
abusing you and they want to leave you
then that's a different story we're not
talking about abuse here I'm talking
regular human beings are showing up and
working and doing everything right it is
not worth you constantly firing and them
quitting and leaving and you training
another butt-buddy
another person you need to know what
you're worth and how many hours you put
into it multiply do you want to go
through another hundred hours times two
hundred dollars that's 20 grand you want
to go through that again do you really
want to do that if not figure out a way
to make that work point number seven
constantly thinking about this is a time
waster constantly thinking about people
who left you you know I can't believe he
left me she went to competitor he went
to this he's doing that they left you
breakups happen divorces happen when you
break up she's going to go with another
guy when you break up with a guy he's
going to go another girl
just what's going to happen it stinks
it's not good people think it's you
you're not good enough you're not this
do not blame figure out what happened
move on and you'll find the right people
you know especially the people that you
know there was conflict it was something
going on they just wasn't a fit that's
going to happen if you constantly worry
about people who quit on you or left you
your constant going to feel like you're
not good enough you're not this is a
listen what can you do to improve move
on and go find another person number
eight constantly spending time on social
media on non effective social media
mixing on what I mean by this
newsfeed on Facebook I'll give you some
stats on a study of entrepreneur did on
which websites are the biggest
time-wasting website 41% at a time what
do you think is a number one time
wasting website in the world what do you
think it is Facebook
41% 37% is LinkedIn believe it or not
Yahoo's at 31% Google is at 28 you may
ask how is Yahoo head of Google because
yahoo has yahoo horoscope and there's a
lot of people that watch Yahoo horoscope
Yahoo movies for waste of time to get on
there to see what the horoscope is
Twitter 8% Pinterest 4% solution here's
the solution because some people it's
automatic newsfeed oh my gosh let me see
what Saul did you see what happened
there's this Marco Rubio say this
Hillary Cooper nice Anders Kobe didn't
say that about Steph Curry oh my gosh
Adele's loose he'll oh all this stuff we
do we're gone for 30 minutes what's the
solution for your mind to stop doing it
very simple every time you go on news
feed or anything that's during business
hours that's not scheduled do 20
push-ups I guarantee you after about 80
push-ups your shoulders going to tell
you stop checking newsfeed find a way to
punish yourself when you're going on
newsfeed too often if you don't want to
do 20 push-ups do 20 squats
regardless figure out a way for your
body to feel what happens every time you
get on newsfeed believe me this is
effective and it works number 9 wasting
time with online office butterflies
wasting time with office butterflies
this is you ever have people in your
office they just want to come and talk
you're like they'll come in your office
and they'll sit down and you're looking
at them you're saying why sky sitting in
my office right now well what happened
here did you just come in my office and
sat down so how do you go about fixing
this well first let me give you some
stats 36 percent people say dealing with
annoying co-workers is their biggest
waste of time 36% say it's their biggest
waste of time twenty three point four
percent say socializing with co-workers
was their number-one distraction at work
that means one out of four person one
out of four people said the number one
biggest distraction is socializing with
co-workers so how do you go about fixing
it there are some systems you have one
someone comes to you they want to talk
to you what's the outcome I got
something going as this important can we
talk later can we talk after hours yes
cool I got to get back to
boom you do it if they come to my office
there's a reason why I have a standing
desk now you know I'm standing up but if
I have a desk and I'm behind the desk
someone comes into my office if I'm done
I walk around literally stand up and
walk around and go to the or Center
anything else no okay we're good I got
to make some calls okay so that's very
obvious and eventually people will know
what you do to not be a time waster it's
very effective to use that been using it
for many many years
number 10 too many meetings people have
way too many meeting out just
counselling meetings meetings meetings
47 percent say their biggest time
wasters having way too many meetings to
attend now I ran a sales organization
for nearly 15 years and meetings are
part of our gig but they're got to be
effective you know I used to hold
meetings and it wasn't affected because
value wasn't provided and people don't
have a problem with effective meetings
that's providing value we trained on
Tuesday evenings and Saturday mornings
and I had full timers meetings on
Mondays and every once in a while we
would do some product presentation on
some kind of a 401k annuity insurance
throughout the day which was effective
they're learning
people are learning but having a meeting
just to have a meeting constantly it
burns people out so be very streamlined
about what meetings you're putting
together and be very effective the
moment you're holding your meeting be
clear about what the purpose of the
meeting is so when the meeting starts
either you say this let me tell what's
the outcome of this meeting boom boom
boom and if nobody says that you ask
okay before we get started can somebody
tell me what's the outcome of this
meeting what's the outcome of this
meeting it's boom boom boom okay great
let's go and get started what's the
outcome in this meeting boom boom boom
let me tell you what if you're the
presenter the outcome of this meeting is
I'm looking for boom boom boom what's
the outcome of the meeting either way
get to the outcome of the meeting
okay time waster number 11 TV time
waster number 11 TV very simple solution
cancel cable just cancel cable I don't
need to spend a lot of time if you know
more than two shows on national
television you're watching way too much
TV I normally don't know any hit songs
that are modern and I don't know any TV
shows because I don't watch TV cable and
I don't listen to radio you'll sit in my
car if you ever get a Mike on radio
stunts because somebody drove it before
me I never listen to I can't listen to
the line I can't think about last time I
listened to radio the only time I ever
did is I said and somebody else was
driving me I don't listen to radio
TV cancel cable time Western number 12
taking calls from friends during
business hours you know I had a
conversation with one of our co-workers
I said look is there a reason why every
day about six seven times a day I see
your wife calls and you pick up and you
step away and you're having meetings you
just step up you know step away what's
my wife called I said listen my wife and
I work together but during business
hours I'm the CEO
she runs operations this is not a time
to sit around and just talk about
everything with life we can talk about
that during bed this morning or
breakfast the bed at night or breakfast
this morning you know that makes sense I
said just maybe you have a different
system about it you know it's still
distracting because sometimes you're at
work and maybe your husband is home
taking care of the kids or wife is I'm
taking care of the kids and just did you
see the kid did this the kid did that
and the husband's getting distracted oh
my god my kids everything okay so now
you can be effective for two hours
because all you're thinking about is the
kids so there is a balance to know on
how to not disrupt somebody while you
are working for you to have some
standards with your family to talk about
that but the other thing is friends
calling hey bro what's going on hey bro
what's going on very simple I'm at work
can't talk now I'll call afterwards or
if somebody calls one time goes to
message great not an emergency they call
twice they didn't leave a message on the
first time it's still not an emergency
if someone calls three times it's
probably an emergency and I'll pick up
not once or twice friends want to just
call and talk and all that other stuff
we'll have time for that later on the
drive home not right now point number 13
time waster number 13 chasing the big
accounts in sales let me explain to what
I mean by this you know you know the
sink oh my goodness if we land this 10
million dollar account I'm set if we get
this one guy I mean we're going to be
millionaires if we close this deal it's
a hundred and ninety six thousand dollar
Commission check to me if I close this
other insurance or annuity I'm going to
be making ninety nine thousand dollars
it's amazing okay and they chase big
sales and you know what happens when
you're chasing big sales and you don't
close big sales you're at a business you
know how often that happens all the time
this is what happens all the time what's
the solution
have a big net of people you're going
after have a big net of clients that
you're going after maybe for one I had a
big whale list I've had the list with
big whales and big accounts I've had a
list I've had many lists like that but
for every one name on this side there
was 50 names on this side for every one
name that's a whale on this side it was
50 names on this side and I'm going
through this every day and I'm following
up with us every 90 days going through
this every day this keeps me in business
this one is going to be exciting and
dessert once I get it but I've never
built my business on a big sale or one
big guy or one big dish build your
business on this and this will
eventually happen okay if you focus too
much on this you could be running out of
gas and going out of business because
all you've been hoping on is this big
sell that's going to change your life
you know what's even worse than a big
sell you lean towards is when you close
the sale and then it falls through and
then you slow down for two weeks then
you go out of business or very close to
it you don't want to do that okay
time waster number fourteen is reading
the wrong books yeah one time there's
this consulting that every time I would
talk to him about social media there was
nothing new he knew about social media
but every time I read to talk to him
about new novels or young adult books he
had read every single one of them so
wait a minute you're a marketing expert
how do you not read marketing books or
go to marketing convention but you know
all the books are 14 15 16 year-olds
read how's that possible men you're like
in your 40s how is that possible
oh you're right you know but man I mean
it's business you got to grow how did
you have you read this book have you
read Jab Jab you read that have no I
haven't but I'm getting to it and then
then you're not competitive then you've
been off the game for five ten years
you're about to go out of business you
got to go get a job you're not going to
make it end as an entrepreneur like this
and that's what happens because you got
to stay up to date you cannot read the
wrong books Fifty Shades of Grey ain't
going to teach you marketing Twilight
ain't gonna teach you marketing none of
that stuff business books are going to
teach you things and keep you edgy where
people want to stay in business with you
and not only that clients know that
you're in the hunt learning because
you've read the books they take you more
seriously if you're feeding your mind so
solution very simple if you have to read
a young adult or whatever book it is
do it Sunday don't do it throughout the
day at all do it on Sundays do it on
days that have nothing to do with your
business and in the last one I'll tell
you is too much party it's a time waster
and I'll say why too much party you know
the average age of a follower here is
somewhere on the mid-20s
people that watch the videos on YouTube
and then Facebook is also in the earlier
20s mid 20s
that means you party because that's the
age we party and I'll tell you for
myself I party very very hard when I was
young very very hard when I was in the
military I partied very how my party
really started after the military once I
went into the military an army all you
do is work hard lift weights and go
party that's what you do
so when I got out of the military I
wanted to be the Middle Eastern version
of Arnold Schwarzenegger some
bodybuilding I'm working at a gym and if
you've ever worked at a gym guess who
knows about all the best parties and
clubs to go to people who work at a gym
I don't know why it's just kind of how
things are right so is party party party
Thursday night ladies night Friday night
Saturday Sunday boom then I become an
entrepreneur and I noticed the trend
Thursday party two o'clock in the
morning come on three tired
eight o'clock out worker you're like a
zombie Friday party night let's go out
2:30 come home boom tire Saturday poom
then you notice you're burning out and
then well but you don't sir I'm 20 I can
hang I can do that that's fine I
guarantee you guarantee you no one is
sharper nobody is sharper person who
parties very hard to 2:30 in the morning
there's no way in the world you're going
to be sharper at an 8 o'clock meeting
then somebody who didn't party hard the
night before and it was sharp there's no
way in the world you're your verge
you're better version of staying focused
it's unfortunate how many times people
drag this out for party now if you
really cannot go away with party no
problem guess what
do it when you're traveling go work your
money make 5 grand and go to Spain a
party that's fine
go to Hawaiian party go to New York and
party on vacation but when you party
Saturday night and your recovery Sunday
you don't read your brain is not able to
because you're alcohol all this stuff
you're sweating it out you don't have
the energy to store information very
well then you waste the 24 hours so it
all depends on how big of an athlete you
want to be if you want to be a super
super super super
great entrepreneur then there's a
certain level of obsessiveness that
comes with that Kobe is obsessive you
know Steph Curry is obsessive Jordan is
obsessive now Jordan party but Jordan
also busted his butt to make sure he
showed up and then offseasons he party
everyone knows he partied during
offseason but his offseason was still
better than 99.99999% of people that had
offices and he was working very hard to
get that key stay focused to develop
yourself as an entrepreneur instead of
being so focused on partying what
everybody is going on Thursday Friday
Saturday night
for you to stay fresh for the mind to
come out and solve the right problems
clothes say the right things and
energized inject energy into everybody
and move your business to the next level
so I will most likely have all these
typed out if you see it on youtube go to
Patrick beta be calm and look for the
time waster video this will be on the
bottom of it you'll be able to download
it or pick it up for yourself to look at
and find out which one of them you're
doing well maybe going to teach this to
your employees to your staff to your
Salesforce and start teaching people how
to get better at not wasting their time
while they're building a business for
themselves and if you haven't subscribed
to this channel whether you going to
watch this on entrepreneur Network value
tame and maybe this video came somewhere
else my website is Patrick weight David
calm you'll see it right here
Patrick wait Davie calm and if you
haven't subscribed to this YouTube
channel click on this bottom button
right here and be sure to subscribe to
this channel thanks for watching
take care
you